what's going on guys this is Rob and
Marvel has officially rebooted the
ultimate universe as always you'll find
a link to the playlist at the end of the
video in case you need to get caught up
but this is self-contained so it's
pretty easy to follow so this initially
picks up basically an Asgard with the
ultimate universe's version of Dr Doom
and Iron Man now again this is all kind
of starting from scrap so you don't need
to have read anything before this to
understand what's going on the long and
short of this and it'll be explained
exceedingly well is that these guys are
here in Asgard to grab somebody and as
they're kind of looking around making
sure that like the jig's not up like
there's no guards coming or anything
along those lines Dr Doom looks through
the little peephole and he asks the
question can you hear me is anyone in
there and this guy's response is go away
right I don't want food I don't want
drink I desire neither company nor
conversation do yourself a favor and
walk away right but the cool thing is
that Dr Doom's like that's cool man
because we're not here with food or
water we're we're here with freedom so
they literally blow the door
down and get this guy out only for us to
find out it's the ultimate Universe
version of Thor now let me tell you guys
something man there's like the main
Marvel Universe version of Thor right
you walk into a comic book store right
now and you say I want to read a Thor
Comic they're going to give you a comic
book that comes from the main Marvel
Universe and he's kind of cool sometimes
I guess depending on the situation like
when he beat the crap out of Iron Man
that was amazing but by and large he's
just like the guy who's there who's the
king of Asgard Thor in the Ultimate
Universe son this guy doesn't give a
damn dud this guy will attack and crush
anybody who's foolish enough to come
against him kind of a funny thing in the
original Ultimate Universe he was
introduced as what was basically a crazy
guy he was locked in a mental
institution because he was just some
dude babbling around about how he was
like the son of Odin right like the kind
of thing that crazy people say but
nonetheless this guy is like the
definition of hardcore and so once Dr
Doom and we can call him iron lad even
though Tony Stark goes by the name iron
lad right that's all I'll kind of
explain here in a second Thor ends up
traveling to what is kind of like the
Throne of Asgard and ends up coming
across lady CIF now one of the cool
things that's still intact here is that
in the main Marvel Universe and in fact
they're continuing it here in the
Ultimate Universe but in the main marway
Universe Heim doall was for years and
years and years the guy who stood watch
at Asgard and saw everything going on
across the nine rails nothing escaped
his gaze which is creepy when you think
about it but in more recent years
Heimdall was killed and his sister CIF
took his place in the Ultimate Universe
they're very much continuing this threat
now it's not really hit on in any
uncertain terms right it's not like an
obvious thing but what it looks like
here is much like in the main Marvel
Universe Thor and Lady CF have a
romantic history together and and that's
by and large just kind of like a core
part of their character's history so
much so that when Adam Warlock first
appeared in Marvel Comics The Dude
literally took off to space and tried to
like force C to marry him and like him
and Thor got into a fight it was like
Adam warlock's second appearance in
marel comics now one of the things that
happens here is that lady CF refers to
Thor as a traitor for those of you guys
who didn't see the original four videos
that we did that led into this reboot
it's okay it'll actually be explained
over the course of this so give me like
two or three minutes and you won't feel
left out but the thing about this is
that Thor is literally just waiting on
Muir right like he's gone to get his
hammer and that's one of the cool things
because at the end of the day these
other ASG Guardians step up with the
intention of like challenging him
defeating him forcing him back into his
cell and probably taking Iron Man and Dr
Doom prisoner as well right the response
of Iron Man not a chance blast these
guys and it's like get your hammer and
let's go man like if hitting Nails means
that much to you right grab your hammer
let's go and the funny thing is that
this Asgardian makes this comment and he
says if you want Muir so bad Come and
Get It traitor and the response of Thor
is has it been so long that Asgard has
forgotten I don't have to and he just
summons the hammer to himself It's
pretty dope and then he becomes like the
Thor that we're all familiar with kind
of a funny thing right the version of
Thor that you saw in really like
Infinity war and Avengers ingame with
like the six lights on his chest that
was from the original ultimate Thor in
fact his original Hammer was powered
through technology and then eventually
he got Muir later on down the line in
the Ultimate Universe it was actually
pretty dope to be honest with you guys
if you never read the original Ultimate
Universe Thor I mean it was a little
wonky for a little while but it was also
pretty cool at certain times but Thor
kind of helps these asgardians
understand their place in the bigger
picture that uh when you mess with the
bull you get the horns you know what I
mean like just starts dominating these
guys and then leaves with Iron Man and
so once that happens he actually
activates the bifrost and teleports them
away and in fact CIF has actually pulled
through it or seemingly jumps through it
and so at that point you pick up with
New York and Stark Tower and the
discovered remnants of Captain America
now one of the things that I want to
specify here is that Captain America in
the original Ultimate Universe and we
don't know if they're going to do it
this way here but in the original
Ultimate Universe he was not the first
recipient of the super soldier serum
he's not the original
that was Samuel Jackson Nick Fury in the
comics right like the black guy Nick
Fury he was the first one to get the
super soldier serum he took off right
just vanished went underground nobody
could ever find him but because they
knew it worked then they gave it to
Steve Rogers it was kind of a big change
between like the main Marvel Universe
and the Ultimate Universe which I liked
now the kicker about all this is that
while they are able to analyze the body
of Steve and they are able to decipher
or at least determine that there seem to
be idal signs there indicating that he's
alive what you also get is this kind of
discussion about the super soldier serum
but what they don't know is what will
happen if they just shatter the glass
right will it shatter his body with it
who knows what's going to happen and so
before they do anything they're kind of
like waiting to find a more safer way of
getting him out so you get this really
cool moment where like Thor's talking to
him right like he asks Iron Man like can
he hear us and his response is like we
don't fully know right like he shouldn't
fully regain Consciousness until we're
further along and thawing him out and
the response of Thor is so he might and
if he might then there are words that
should be said and he says Hear Me
brother I would free you now is I would
free any chains who deserve them not
were the risks not grave and the cost so
high but you have my word should the
time come when such a choice must be
made you will be freed better to die as
such than helpless and hopeless trapped
in a frozen hell now that's like perfect
example of ultimate Thor this guy was
all about speeches man and they were
like some of the most dope speeches ever
the only instance of there being like a
speech that Thor gave in oh my God in
Marvel Comics that was not in the
Ultimate Universe was in Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers The
Last Ride of Thor and Hyperion do you
guys remember that son son son man like
hyperion's like Thor will you wait for
me in Asgard and he's like brother today
I will race you there and they like
charge headlong into an army of the
beyonders and just get annihilated it's
amazing like it is one of the coolest
moments ever in the history of Marvel
Comics we'll have another link to that
in the end of this video in case you
just want to watch that video it's
really really amazing right it's really
really cool but what they end up finding
out is that like lady CF is there with
them and it's one of these things where
she's like those are strong words right
but promise promising Freedom when you
don't even have your own seems
disingenuous Thor and what you get here
is kind of an
unspoken Alliance of sorts right and the
reason for that is because lady CF
doesn't actually know what's going on
and not even Thor fully knows what's
going on as far as lady SI is concerned
this is the way things have always been
this is the way things are supposed to
be that Thor is a traitor to the throne
of Asgard that he had killed Odin Loki
took his place and that was it right the
response of Dr Doom and of Iron Man is
actually none of what you're seeing here
is real none of this is how it's
supposed to be and when the question
that's asked is how so the response of
Iron Man is you're supposed to be the
king of Asgard Thor you were supposed to
succeed your father as king not to be
branded a traitor and thrown into a
prison cell for the rest of your days
and so what Dr Doom does is he gives
this kind of just great explanation on
what's going on which I'll give you guys
here for those of you guys who either
need to get caught up or need to refresh
pressure right what he says is the ruler
of this Earth our imperator is a man
called the maker and while he's trapped
inside his quote unquote future city
this just giant Dome that exists out
there in the world we are presented with
an opportunity we can change this world
back into the world it was supposed to
be you have to understand and this is
the heart of the matter the maker is
from a different universe and he arrived
here with a very specific mission to
systematically erase the world's heroes
from existence now before we continue on
this is something that I want to explain
here because it is an important thing so
in Marvel Comics The Ultimate Universe
is known as Earth 1610 1610 you guys
know that from the Miles Morales Beyond
spiderverse ENT the spiderverse you know
spider-verse is like the greatest movie
ever in the history of comic book movies
that whole franchise right like you guys
know that the thing about this in and
what's really kind of cool is the
Ultimate Universe did return kind of
after Secret Wars in 2015 Hickman's
ignoring all of that as far as we're
concerned the Ultimate Universe has been
gone ever since the collapse of the
Multiverse at the end of his Avengers
New Avengers run and the start of Secret
Wars The Maker comes from that original
Ultimate Universe just like Miles
Morales did the difference is that the
maker ended up going into the Multiverse
to either try to find the original
Ultimate Universe or if he couldn't find
it to basically terraform to to change
Another Universe into the ultimate
universe that he remembers that's what
he did here that Dr Doom kind of
continues on and he says the maker was
able to do this by denying them the
circumstances and the events that would
have transformed them into what they
were supposed to be he was able to do
that because he arrived in our universe
with the knowledge of the history of our
Earth's Heroes and when C asked how can
you know such a thing the response of
Doom is because when I was his prisoner
a captive and a tool for decades I was
able to steal his files so I know what
the maker knows and so what they're
looking to do here is basically set
things back to rights by going through
and saying okay so here's what's
supposed to happen Thor is supposed to
be the king of Asgard so we have to fix
that we end up getting just like these
really amazing I guess I guess kind of
like this list of where these different
superheroes stand that Steve Rogers is
quote unquote undefined nobody
necessarily knows right Bucky Barnes
he's believed to be dead that Robert
Grayson isn't active right jack Monroe
isn't active Thor Odin son isn't active
and the list kind of goes on and on and
on Reed Richards is controlled and in
fact for those of you guys who weren't
following the original story this
version of Dr Doom that you see is Reed
it's this reality's version of Reed
Richards not Victor Von Doom right so
it's kind of a change from what we're
used to right Ben Grim dead it's all
these things where like these Heroes
that were familiar with are basically
done and gone now guys like Bruce Banner
The Incredible Hulk they're listed as
being controlled because he's a part of
What's called the Illuminati but what
these guys have to do here is in turn go
and grab the files that the maker had
hidden in a different location we end up
discovering that this location is
Latveria but Latveria is not home to
Victor Von Doom and in fact and
seemingly laveria was at some point a
kind of main base of operations for the
maker which seems pretty ironic the fact
that he had Doom under his control and
that while it's not really Victor Von
Doom at the end of the day it still
seems so similar enough that it still
kind of works but once they make their
way through a force field and Thor of
course helps them do it by just using
his hammer and busting the thing down
because you know Thor's
amazing what Doom says is that once they
found all these different artifacts they
have to be wary of the fact that there
will be defenses right that these
repositories these just gigantic
containers that house all this
information they have to get them back
and then go through them all and find
out what changes the maker made because
we know that he did things like he
stopped the radioactive spider from
biting Peter Parker so Peter Parker
never became Spiderman he's just like a
kid who's out there in the world just
sort of doing his thing it was small
stuff like that right imagine that on an
entire planetary scale billions of lies
that have been altered and changed
irrevocably by one guy they have to sort
through all of that in order to get
things to the way that they're supposed
to be the problem with this is that
before anybody can really make a move
Thor's stabbed in the back and he's
actually stabbed in the back by Captain
Britain a member of the Illuminati
because remember one of the things that
the maker had set up here with the
Illuminati team is that unlike the main
Marvel Universe where it's Reed Richards
and uh Black Panther and name with the
Submariner and Professor Xavier and then
eventually Captain America blackbolt
which nobody knows why he was on that
team and that guy's useless as tits and
a Bor Haw but the fact remains like
while they were there and they were kind
of operating behind the scenes and they
were sort of watching everything unfold
and sharing information preventing
conflicts before they ever became major
things the Illuminati in the Ultimate
Universe or at least here in this line
they're completely corrupt that what
they do is this kind of like game of
conflicts right that each of them leads
an individual nation and that they play
this game where like the Incredible
Hulks Nation will be like quote unquote
the bad guys and that the other nations
will band together and they'll defeat
the Incredible Hulks Nation but then
after the Incredible Hulks nation is
defeated then like the nation of another
group will see this as a opportunity to
seize control and they'll become the bad
guy and what it does is it constantly
keeps people distracted from the reality
of the world that they live in which is
basically a giant box and the people
pulling the strings are controlling the
lives that they live in this instance
the Illuminati and the maker it's a very
very intricate and Incredibly well
constructed ruse on the entire human
race but this guy right Captain Britain
is basically one of them now what's so
cool about this is that this guy this
Captain this is Henry dugy right we know
that from the original ultimate Invasion
issue number two number three but so
it's not actually a descendant of Von
Doom at least not that we're aware of
but this could be one of those things
where they restructure it and they
basically turn him into Dr Doom but
regardless Iron Man just like puts his
hand to this guy's face and fires off
his Repulsor blast and while it's not
enough to kill this guy which that
wasn't necessarily the intention it is
enough to incapacitate him and in fact
we'll actually talk about the Dr Doom
connection here in a second because
following that of course Thor is
basically taken by Tony Stark and Dr
Doom back to Stark Tower to try to offer
some kind of medical assistance to get
this guy healed which you know I mean
being stabbed in the chest this despite
being a god some kind of medical
attention right but what you do is you
jump back to laveria with Henry talking
to the rest of the Illuminati and what
he says here is that he's been
completely disfigured right now the
reality is that it's just his eye but
the way in which he refers to it the way
in which he talks about it this is a
Cornerstone of Dr Doom because one of
the things that we had never seen until
we got to Secret Wars in 2015 was the
extent of Dr Doom's facial damage the
ity here is that we didn't know for like
decades in marel comics we didn't know
if this guy was really disfigured or if
Dr Doom believed he was disfigured we
never knew the answer to that question
because you never really saw him without
his mask and the very few times where
you did see that Marvel stories would
contradict each other and so because of
this this is one of those instances
where like it ties kind of into that Dr
du Mythos right I'm so disfigured my
face is torn up you know all that kind
of stuff and this guy's probably
insanity and most likely hubis could
very well lead him down that path but we
don't necessarily know the reason for
this and the reason why it's so cool is
because what this does is it allows the
Illuminati to concoct this plant where
they can make Tony Stark look like the
villain and when the questions asked as
to how they're going to do that the
Incredible Hulk who leads the children
of Eternal Light he says we regret the
loss of your eye Captain but we have all
been wondering exactly how to deal with
the vacuum of power on that continent
and to claim it for ourselves I now see
a path forward he does not know it but
the boy has given us North America all
we have to do is take it and when the
question is asked how the response of
Hulk is by committing the acts of a
tyrant or Worse those of a terrorist
that in effect what they're saying is
that Tony Stark left New York he left
North America he traveled to Latveria a
legitimate Sovereign Nation and and
launched an attack against the person
who leads it he attacked a head of state
this is like you leaving North America
and then flying to like Canada and
attacking the Canadian Prime Minister I
don't remember his name was it Trudeau
or something like that attacking that
guy it would be considered an act of
political terrorism right and so because
of that it gives the ability for
Latveria quote unquote to launch an
attack against North America and in fact
they specifically Target Stark tower now
when the question is asked by Viper like
how do we sell it the response of Hulk
is we do what we do we tell lies so
large that it's inconceivable that they
are fabricated or false and we cover
that with just enough truth to sell it
we put his name on it Stark and when the
question is asked and you think people
will believe it when we blame the boy
the response of Hulk is of course they
will after all while it's true that we
are the ones who had control of the
machines it was his family who built
them right so one of the things that
you'll notice here is that like like the
Incredible Hulk in this reality is very
manipulative and very very dark and in
fact it's a wild situation because in
the original Ultimate Universe The
Incredible Hulk was basically mindless
he wasn't nearly as strong as his main
Marvel Universe counterpart but he was
Mindless he was a cannibal he would eat
people it was crazy like he ripped
Wolverine in half at one point it was
nuts right it was crazy some of the
stuff that he did and so what you do is
you pick up with this that takes place
about a week later right and it's
basically this news blip where it says
against a backdrop of global concern and
international Aid it is with gratitude
and great sorrow that we do our best to
reflect on the events of last week and
while all of us here and millions around
the world still wait for answers about
what happened that day for now all we
have are questions thousands remain
missing and while almost no physical
evidence remains local and international
agencies using GPS digital IDs and other
forensic data have been able to create a
database of Unfortunate Souls who may
have been in the blast of the terrorist
attack below me those potential victims
names are scrolling on the screen people
who according to both the data and the
experts who analyzed it were believed to
have been near the corporate
headquarters of stain Stark when the
event occurred authorities need all the
help they can get so anyone who can
confirm or deny any of names please
contact them immediately right it makes
it look like it was Stark that just
launched an attack that stks the bad guy
here and so this kind of continues on
right it says and while domestically
these are troubling strange times it
seems that these events are not
contained by our borders in another part
of the world a car explosively collided
with a bicycle in the streets and while
the driver remains in serious condition
the 15-year-old girl who was hit by the
car escaped esed without a scratch on
her elsewhere in several of the dynastic
strongholds of the upper and lower
kingdoms there are reports of an
outbreak of regional infighting and
perhaps open insurgence due to the
volatile nature of the conflict and in
accompanying media blackout there has
been very little available coverage of
the event and all that we have we are
sharing with you now and we will keep
you updated as we learn more it's just
kind of this continued thing of painting
these guys as villains now this is when
it gets cool right because what this
news guy says is he says finally we end
tonight's coverage with the biggest
underlying mystery regarding the recent
attack why would a teenage boy commit
this terrible act some have suggested
that it was because of his father and
Godfather's recent passing others have
assumed that it was some simple Madness
we will continue to try and find answers
to these questions but is Tony Stark is
believed to have been in the blast it is
safe to assume that he too has perished
and it's very possible we may never know
why he did it only for us to find out
seemingly Tony Stark is completely alive
so the question has to be asked since
the Illuminati launched their strike
they made their first move now Tony
Stark is on a quest for vengeance and
Tony Stark in the Ultimate Universe the
original Ultimate Universe this guy was
kind of crazy he was really cool right
so imagine it this way imagine that
someone or a group of people launched an
attack against Robert Downey Jor Tony
Stark what do you think he would do in
that situation if someone tried to kill
him so with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end the
Ultimate Universe officially spins out
in January starting with Jonathan
Hickman Spider-Man and I am excited
about that I am so hyped make sure you
guys check the link to this playlist if
you need to get caught up and we'll
catch you all later peace